>> All right Charles, what do you think?
>> Okay, so being in the version space just means
that you're consistent with the, data that you see. Right?
>> Good. Mm-hm.
>> Okay, so we should be able to very quickly go through this. So X1,
just copy X1 over. Well, if we look at the training data, in the first
case, X1 is zero and the output is zero. Second case, X1 is one and
the output is one. So that is, in fact, consistent with just always copying X1.
>> So that is in the
version space, right?
>> Right. And without even having to think about it, since x1 is in
the version space, doing the opposite of
x1 can't possibly be in the version space.
>> Agreed.
>> So let's skip that.
>> Looking at x2, we can see that in the first case, you go
x2 0, c of x is 0. Yeah, so yeah that's looking good. That's consistent
so far. But then on the next row you get 0 and then you
get the, opposite of 0. You get 1, the compliment of 0. So, that definitely
is inconsistent with just copying over X2, so you can't have X2
and by very similar reasoning you can't have the opposite of X2.
>> Agreed.
>> Okay, so, true is clearly not consistent because
we got a 0 once and a 1 once.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And by the same argument false is not consistent because we
got a zero once and a one once. Now or, let's see or.
>> But in case it's not clear, I probably could have been clearer about
this, but here, zeroes and falses are the same thing and ones and trues
are the same thing.
>> Right. Just like in C.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay. So I just assume everything you do
is written in C, Michael, so, it just works that
way. In fact there's a C right up there at
the top of the, at the top of the slide.
>> Yeah so I feel like I should do this. Now I understand what's going on.
>> Right, now it's in C.
>> Much better. Okay, so, or. Or means if either one of them
is true, then you say yes and, huh! That's actually consistent with or.
>> Yep.
>> Hm. But it is not consistent with and,
because one and zero would be zero, not one. Second
case, XOR, well, I already know it's consistent with XOR,
because I happen to know that that's the target concept.
>> Yeah.
>> And an equiv would be not
consistent. Though interestingly, not equivalent would be consistent.
>> Yes, because not equivalent is XOR.
>> Oh, yeah, that's right.
>> All
right, so that's, yeah, that's it, X1, OR, AND, XOR.
>> Excellent.
>> Cool.